[Music]
what computer science paper most
influenced you
this came out when i was a high school
student but
the universal gripper which was
basically just a balloon filled with
coffee grounds and it was able to pick
up a wide variety of objects and that
was a very cool paper of like wow you
know the stuff that i'm doing in high
school actually can go beyond and even
very simple techniques can be very
powerful i'd say one of the very first
deep learning papers that i read was
deepmind's paper on building autonomous
agents that can learn the game of atari
from scratch this was incredibly
influential to me there was a paper
called equality of opportunity and
supervised learning
that came out the year i started my phd
and it was about fairness and machine
learning which ended up being a huge
component of my research so i was
thinking about how machine learning
impacts people and maybe impacts
different groups differently and that
has really changed the way i think about
ai and ai's responsibility in society
it's actually a book
by mark rayburn called legged robots
that balance
a group of papers from
sociologists and anthropologists that
were talking about disparities in health
care and that was those papers were from
a long time ago so they weren't really
related to computer science but
reading them sort of made me realize how
important that work was to the type of
machine learning applied to healthcare
that i was working on at the time
and so there was a paper that came out
back in 2013
by some people here and at disney
research
i think the paper is called
computational design of
mechanical characters
and
this was a really exciting paper to me
at the time because it was the first one
or one of the first ones
that went from okay you make a digital
character and you wanted to do some sort
of task and then you want to fabricate
it at the end how do you do all these
three things in a way that's in some way
optimal and this was sort of coming out
at the same time that i was applying for
phd programs and when i saw that i was
like okay the thing that i'm thinking i
want to do that's not crazy there's
people working in this direction it's
definitely going to be possible let's
let's make it happen
[Music]
you